il foule la terre ferme pour la première
fois après plus de deux mois d'Hérens en
mer mardi le marin australien Timothy
Shadok accompagné de sa chienne Bella
arrivée au Mexique exténué c'est au bord
de ce cratère sur les îles Galapagos que
le jeune Axel huit ans se promet avec
ses parents le 7 juillet dernier le
senti en terre est à 2 m du précipice
sans barrière et alors qu'il commence à
retourner vers leur voiture les parents
entendent un cri derrière eux repérez
lundi après de 2000 km des côtes par un
tonier Mexicain le navigateur prévoyait
de parcourir 6000 km à bord de son
catamaran pour jeter l'encre en
Polynésie française mais une mer agitée
endommage rapidement son navire et met
hors service les équipements
électroniques l'enfant vient de survivre
à une chute 200 mètres freinée par la
densité de la végétation à l'intérieur
du cratère il est remonté puis
transporté à l'hôpital où les médecins
ne constatent que quelques ecchy Moses
et deux fractures à la clavicule et
l'omoplate
il va rester qui va partir le dossier
brûlant au sommet de l'exécutif à
quelques jours du remaniement se tenait
hier le dernier dîner à l'Élysée avant
la pause estivale à table des ministres
qui ne savent pas le sort qui leur sera
réservé quand vous voyez que le bilan le
fiasco des 100 jours d'apaisement comme
ils aimaient à le faire c'est que à la
fin rien ne change pour que rien ne
change c'est un problème que d'avoir une
première ministre qui n'a jamais demandé
la confiance au Parlement
Emmanuel Macron est peut-être la seule
personne du pays à avoir encore
confiance en sa première ministre et un
remaniement dans les prochains jours il
y a des ministres qui vont quitter le
gouvernement ça fait une drôle
d'ambiance quand même la vie ne s'arrête
pas qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
vous dise moi je n'ai vu que des gens
charmants qui étaient heureux de d'être
ensemble pour un moment de convivialité
c'est pas tous les jours
pas tous les jours comme ça c'est c'est
un peu compliqué la vie de ministre moi
je vais pas me plaindre moi j'ai déjà
dit que je trouvais logique finalement
cette reconduction et on pourrait dire
Emmanuel Macron Emmanuel Macron
reconduit Emmanuel Macron c'est à dire
que
qu'est-ce que c'est qui s'est passé oui
mais précisément qu'est-ce que le
bornisme si ce n'est le macronisme on
vérité le maintien d'Elizabeth borne à
Matignon c'est d'abord cette prime à
l'échec à la médiocrité la France n'est
pas apaisée contrairement à ce qu'avait
demandé Emmanuel Macron madame borne
n'est pas capable de trouver des
majorités et d'élargir des majorités
donc par conséquent elle n'est
évidemment pas à sa place en réalité je
ne suis pas pour qu'on amuse les
Français pendant l'été sur un soi-disant
casting qui changerait pour continuer la
même politique et réalité c'est que
personne n'avait vraiment envie
visiblement d'aller se coller à ce
boulot parce que la politique qui est
menée par le gouvernement est une
politique qui appauvrit la France qui
crée des crises multiples barbecue
Pauline n'est même piscine sur ces
images qui datent du 14 juillet la cité
du docteur Heym à Cavaillon célèbre la
fête nationale problème cette fête n'a
jamais été déclarée et les organisateurs
sont soupçonnés d'être en réalité des
trafiquants de drogue une découverte
archéologique incroyable en Chine
regardez ce fossile remarquablement
préservé il s'agit d'un petit mammifère
voyez sur la gauche plantant s'écrou
dans les côtes d'un dinosaure faisant
trois fois sa taille la mairie elle de
son côté a réagi elle a porté plainte
selon nos informations pour mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui et occupation
illégale du domaine public et enfin elle
a surtout demandé à ce qu'on le retrouve
qui a commandé les jeux gonflables
comment ils ont été payés et par qui
figé en pleine action dans la cendre
d'une éruption volcanique il y a 125
millions d'années preuve pour les
scientifiques qu'il existait à l'époque
des petits mammifères capables
d'attaquer un dinosaure adulte ça c'est
n'importe quoi c'est du n'importe quoi
parfois c'était le graphique le week-end
du 14 juillet les jeunes ils avaient
chauds et ils ont les graines du
quartier après la initiative de faire
rafraîchir les jeunes tout simplement
d'où vient ce cylindre et échouer sur
une plage en Australie c'est la question
que se pose les autorités et des
internautes après l'apparition de
l'objet de 2 m 50 dollars sur la côte
ouest du pays pour la deuxième nuit
consécutive et une tentative de
cambriolage a eu lieu au domicile de
Jane Birkin décédé dimanche dernier
c'est une amie de Jane Birkin qui a
donné l'alerte car elle dormait chez
elle
d'un débris
issu d'un engin spatial et là les
enquêteurs du web ont une piste sérieuse
pour beaucoup il s'agit du troisième
étage de ce lanceur de satellite indien